you're not making 250 you're not living
you ain't going on vacation and doing
things you want to do you're not driving
a nice car you're not giving your kids
everything like dude if you have three
kids and you're married and you make 120
000 it's not a lot of money especially
if you live in California or one of
these places when I was broke the
thought of making six figures was like
man this is crazy and then you just look
at inflation and where the world is like
no it's six figures ain't much it's
about figuring out a skill to make 250
Grand because anything less than that is
not much money and a lot of people think
that that's wrong if they get mad if you
say that less than 250 is not much money
but dude